the term motion capture is thrown around
a lot when talking about visual effects
and it conjures up the image of those
big reflected off stuck on actors faces
for longer than 15 years techies have
been working on more effective ways to
capture the movement the universal
capture system or you cap had developed
the early concepts in high-resolution
facial motion capture and the ability to
create realistic digital human
characters their work was brilliantly
realized in the Matrix sequels which set
the stage for the continued development
and the motion capture arts starting
with optical flow a technique that
tracks the motion of every pixel in an
image through a sequence of images you
can pioneered the technology of using
multi high resolution cameras to produce
moving 3d geometry captured from a
performers face this recorded motion
would bring their digital topic angle
doppelgänger to life it's a process we
take for granted but these folks pave
the way the Academy presents a technical
achievement award to Dan papponi Kim
library nice and George Moore Chekov for
their pioneering work and the
development of universal capture at yes
yes the entertainment come on up get
your awards you [ __ ]
okay thank you very much everybody
firstly we would like to thank the
Academy and especially this committee
for all our hard work in researching
this relatively ancient technology that
pioneered facial capture for the movie
business would like to thank our crew at
escape and prior to that at Mannix
especially Austin who's over there in
the audience would like to thank our
families for dealing with the endless
long nights in making these movies and
making the technology would like to
thank our friends at Warner Brothers
would like to thank the Wachowskis and
our friend John Gaeta and also I'd like
to thank Satoshi Ken amaura from Sony HD
without their cameras and their
invention of Sony HD we would have not
been able to make this technique work
finally with Larsa light to work
dedicate this award to the memory of our
good friend Rodney machinae he was a
critical part of making the Matrix
movies and he will be dearly lost
I just wanted to say it's amazing I
haven't been in the industry for 10
years it's so incredible that the
Academy does the research and forms of
these committees to look at these
technologies and recognize them it's
truly amazing for me so thank you very
much for doing that for us appreciate it
we are we only do what we do because we
stand on the shoulders of giants but we
can only climb up to those shoulders
because of the teachers that we had so I
just want to thank all the teachers up
ahead whether they're high school
teachers university teachers my
colleagues George and Kim who taught me
so much
my parents including my mother who
traveled 5,000 miles to be here tonight
and my wife who probably taught me half
of what I know